the last time you were with us Michael
you were talking about Julian Castro who
was announcing his run that day and you
said that that announcement was about as
significant as what you had for
breakfast
well we'll let the viewers decide how
true your porn ossification --zz were
what do you think of the vice
president's race perhaps a little bit
more significant than your breakfast
order I think unfortunately much more
significant than my breakfast order by
the way I think my prediction was
correct because until you just said his
name I had forgotten that who Leon
Castro was running for president at this
point Joe Biden however poses a
significant threat to the president
forget the national polls when you look
at the individuals in Pennsylvania
Michigan Wisconsin he's up between 8 and
10 points over Donald Trump if the
election were held today Joe Biden would
win it possibly in a landslide
almost like we planned this segment
because we actually have one of those
polls from Pennsylvania the Vice former
vice president's home state and he is up
by almost 10 points depending on which
poll you look at over President Trump
what has happened to all the blue-collar
voters that flipped from Obama to Trump
now flipping back to Biden where is the
where has the Republicans lost their way
on this well Joe Biden is going into
this race right now looking pretty clean
he's been out of politics for a few
years and nobody has really been
attacking him for anything other than
giving people back massages and smelling
their hair so he's going in with some
advantage nobody has hit him on his
actual weaknesses he's a liar is
something of an unctuous smiling
politician so they can hit him on not
having a whole lot of substance he's
somewhat corrupt you there was
significant corruption in some of his
son's dealings and China and Ukraine I
would say out of significant allegations
I'm not sure any of them have been
proven yet the going or not though and
in politics is you don't hit somebody on
their weaknesses you hit them on their
strengths Joe Biden's strength is the
idea of being able to connect to the
middle class the guy who rides Amtrak
too and
Delaware the guy who can talk to folks
in an ice cream store better than just
about anybody else his message were told
when he takes the stage is going to be
as a president for everyone he's already
framing this as Biden verse Trump not
even talking about the nomination for
the Democratic Party do you feel as
though that's a little premature should
everyone just sort of get ready to get
the graphics going a Biden verse Trump
certainly it's premature there are 22
other candidates in this race there will
probably be another 22 before the whole
thing is over
I do agree though people that you want
to hit him on his connection to voters
the other strength that he's been
campaigning on is that he has so much
experience he's been in politics for 50
years
he's been in office since he was 26
years old and I think this is the real
place that eventually President Trump
could hit him on if he wins the
nomination which is that in all of those
50 years Joe Biden does not have a
banner accomplishment to his name he's
been in office for 50 years what has he
done
Donald Trump's been into in office for
two years he's had a relatively very
successful presidency I think that's
where you'll be able to see the
distinction now and also it seems as
though the president is laying out
trying to draw this distinction on China
we keep hearing China China China from
President Trump and we know Vice
President Biden is downplayed that
before mr. Noles we appreciate it and we
will check these prognostications the
next time we have yawns - let's see if
you're still batting 100